what is up there reject nation greg and
john
back at it again because it would be
complete
sacrilege if we did not cover
new rock stars loki episode 2
easter eggs and breakdown video details
you and by you he means us that
we specifically the real rejects have
missed i'm excited be forewarned i
wanted to get loki episode 2 up early
today only got an hour and a half of
sleep so
uh the next reaction is not getting
enough that early
i'm good right now i'm sharp right now
let's uh i just gotta maintain
decent sharpness for the next yeah okay
that's that's
the first one cool
[Music]
welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of loki
episode 2
which does not bode well for our future
well that of the sacred timeline or
our own coming environmental doom the
extinction of swallows aren't you
kidding me
we couldn't save the birds as always
there were so many hard to spot
details hidden throughout the day so i'm
gonna break it down
shop by shot for everything you might
have missed support this channel by
checking out our new loki inspired merch
options like the awesome
i bought a shirt where is it it's at
newrockstarsmerch.com
we open on a renaissance fair in oshkosh
wisconsin 1985 the year time travel
fiction really climbed to new popularity
with the release of back to the company
back to that it looks like the first to
swipe past is 2023
telling us that the tva frame of
reference for us is the current mcu
present year of 2024.
hunter c20 tracks the loki variant to
this green tent with a
golden sign out front for a miniature
pony green and gold of course being
loki's colors
also coincidentally crossing in front of
the temp pad is this blonde woman
doesn't look like sophia dimartino but
they are looking for someone who looks
should be looking for someone who looks
like that so this episode ultimately
reveals the variant to be a female
played by sophia dimartino perhaps lady
loki from the comics which is a
reincarnation of loki's soul
in a new female body though if you look
closely to alternate language dubs in
the credits she is credited as
sylvie which could be for sylvie lushton
aka
enchantress sylvia is a girl in broxton
oklahoma when the asgardians relocate
there and that same run in the comics
she wakes up with powers and it's later
suggested
she might have been wholly created by
loki as a kind of joke
i suspect this show might be combining
elements of sylvie with lady loki
but since this show for now considers
her to be a loki variant
i'm just gonna call her lady loki here
let's not get confused here
okay the whole reason we believe lady
loki was coming in the first place
was because of you so i don't need some
enchantress
thoughts being yeah being scrambled up
here in the little noggin
all right enchantress that says suicide
squads business
people gave us brownie points for
guessing she'd show up
when i'm like it's cause eric vos
clearly pointed out that she'd show up
but yeah uh yeah she's she's credited as
enchantress so you're probably right
about some type of mixture but she'll
probably be just lady loki good good
call good call
bonnie tyler's 1984 song holding out for
a hero
is queued up with a recording
[Music]
hold on did lady loki take the time to
audio edit a recording so that it
transitioned on holding out for a hero
or was holding out for a hero already
the music this 1985 renfair had queued
up
either way this is some real joker [ __ ]
that tells us this lady loki has a flare
for the dramatic and is willing to take
her time tinkering with electronics
you know that uh ready for a hero song
is like
in a he-man trailer and oh it's getting
a lot of play
guardians of the galaxy game trailer and
it shows up here in the show
the go-to song now it's every song
played during fast nine and the
prize being the princess sets up our
loki as the hero we're holding out for
chasing his princess oh wow i think the
evil
is actually something else that could
prevail lady lukey pairs her
consciousness with c20 wanda maximoff's
illusion curse is a similar look but
different colors
but here the spell is mind control
something loki previously could only do
with the mind stone in the scepter
but we will soon learn from mobius that
variant loki's have different powers
the close-up of the attempt shoots for a
time door
and miss minutes again miss minutes is a
selectable function
as she is on the elevator maybe at any
given moment they can unleash her as a
weapon
or kind of sound alarm she's kind of
like that microsoft word paper clip
thingy yeah yeah clippy i love that guy
super helpful always helps me write the
best reports
speaking of whom loki asks if miss
minutes is a recording or if she's alive
are you recording or are you alive the
ai question brought back
yeah he tries to swat her and the fact
that miss minutes goes to the effort of
dodging these confirms she exists in the
real world
reacting moment to moment and you can
hear her shoes making noises
watch it where's your manners oh hey
quit it
he's not max and at one point she stands
on the hourglass which remember is the
symbol at the heart of the tva logo
maybe showing that she could have some
authority over the tva
like i theorized she might be linked
with the timekeepers kind of the way the
cree
supreme intelligence is a reactive ai
that controls that society
now on the screen is a multiple choice
question thanos has two apples he eats
both but realizes he wants more he goes
back in time 20 minutes and eats the
apples again
does this mean the apples will not have
existed in the timeline
no because time is constantly happening
b the question doesn't matter because a
branch cannot change another time branch
yeah thanos would have been hungry prior
because the grandfather paradox already
accounted for the change in matter
before
its move i love it all three options are
explanations we have heard in time
travel fiction before
like a being our approach time is just
always happening c
being our this always happened approach
in which things are what they are meant
to be in the future and b
being the correct answer within loki's
logical framework in which
branch timelines cannot affect other
branch timelines they each play out in
real time independently
again again this is why this
channel rocks this is why they are the
rock
stars someone on the crew
for loki took time to do all that
to input all that yeah to create that
and you get someone like the tv
new rockstars to go in there do the
whole enhance effect from every sci-fi
movie and give us this delicious little
easter egg
that's a great easter egg it is it is
and it's like it has
these different theoretical approaches
to time travel with it
clearly work went into that and i really
hope that the design
people who work on these elements of the
show are watching this now to feel that
vindication
most people won't see it you know this
is actually the point mobius later
corrects loki on at the fair
and loki didn't know because he's
slacking off here and i love how it uses
rewinding apples the example doctor
strange used to display time travel
and i'm not a great hungry
also shows that the tva knows who thanos
is and apparently considered his
genocide just part of the sacred
timeline mobius shows some other loki
variants including a blue one
remember loki's natural cross giant form
is variant l1247 but
when you punch up to a close-up it
changes to 67-92
and variant l1247 shows loki as a
cyclist having won the tour de france
then a beastly loki who appears to be
l6792
a bearded loki l 8914 with natural black
horns
and then a loki with a more traditional
viking armor l seventeen
three mobius says each loki has a
different power set but all of them seem
to have the power of
illusion projection though loki corrects
him saying that there's a distinction
between illusion projection and
duplication casting collusion projection
being like when loki projected
shape-shifted forms of cap and odin over
himself or when he projected thor's
severed arm in the dark world
meanwhile duplication casting being
anytime loki tricked other people
with alternate doubles of himself but
this clarification of loki's power set
helps set up loki's sorcery as far more
diverse than we realized for example him
using telekinesis to summon a roomba in
that rockstar
fight something i don't think we had
ever previously seen him do in the rin
fair loki's talky talky talking doesn't
work on mobius and the others
they end up using the reset charge on
the tent this time giving us a close-up
of it it looks like the main chamber
containing this orange fluid but then
the charge releases an upper chamber of
purple fluid that mixes until it reaches
a saturation point that releases this
rainbowy puddle that resets everything
within the radius
it's almost like these are made of
specific amounts of matter
and antimatter that mix together and
that collision
undues the fabric of the nearby reality
and as we see this branch pruned on the
chrome monitor screen
other past branch locations tick past
including ninja velir
that's the artery
thor banner and valkyrie escaped so even
though it seemed like the tva was earth
specific from the animation last episode
they actually oversee all the planets in
the known mcu universe
rensselaer's office has the statue of
timekeeper
right behind her seat just like in the
courtroom and just like in the final
shot of the end credits we now begin in
close up on this one
also notice that zorth and vanth are
holding hourglasses but
ast's arms are outstretched in kind of a
saintly pose
i'm gonna get this out of the way right
now we said in our review for the
episode two reaction you know i don't
know a lot of people don't stick around
for those parts i really
am starting to suspect that the
timekeepers are a
big part of the illusion i think ravona
is secretly like maybe the one in charge
cosmic wonder he even enhanced upon that
theory
with it being that king the conqueror
and her are perhaps maybe
working together and the time keepers
are part of the illusion
so oh man and then loki's pursuit to get
to the time keepers could reveal a more
sinister truth yeah i don't know it
seems like a marvel thing to do to be
like timekeepers are an actual thing but
one day they're gonna get their
switcheroo right in a way that pleases
but i feel like the timekeepers illusion
thing because we've never
met them could work they could yeah yeah
and they're still abstract
we've built up mobius hasn't met them
mobius even begins to say something
about the odd one out but rensselaer
cuts him off
although i shouldn't say that that one
looks like he's got timekeepers i'm
monitoring
every aspect of this case yeah i think
these are more clues that this
timekeeper in particular might have a
special relationship with brent slater
movius points out other mission trophy
artifacts like a snow globe and you can
later see it read
san diego rensselaer says you're not the
only analyst working for me
yeah mobius brings up this other analyst
a few times including this pen from
franklin d roosevelt high school
i don't remember this this must be from
that and unless you keep on the side
it's jimmy woo's witness protection
it's gonna be revealed some other
analysts that might be in the shadows
notice how mobius does not use a coaster
leaving more ring stains on that table
the end credits actually show a ring
stain on his chrono monitor handbook
so here's another possible clue like
maybe the reason mobius doesn't remember
leaving these ring stains is because
this other analyst
is a variant of
oh that totally lines up it seems like
it's due for a twist like that and with
how
all mobius seems to know but then
there's certain things where you like
you think you would know that but
apparently he doesn't know that this
whole thing with about the other
analysts i mean the timekeepers like
they make these employees who work here
and things like that and while
everyone we've seen is different maybe
mobius is special and maybe they do have
like a stockpile of him or something
like that
and talking about like what is the
purpose of life conversation they had
specifically in this episode and him
saying like i'm just glad to know what
my purpose is but then
to deal with a variety who they have
were uh oh that was like
i feel like that could add to his story
instead of just being a cool twist you
know what i mean oh yeah
i mean it could totally put him in a
position to question his entire belief
system position in
space and time and all that stuff and
give him further reason to align further
with you they need to finally get the
jet ski
finally the last shot of the series
rides off from the sunset and then what
does he say
oh wow cut to black
notice how rensselaer signs a report r
slayer a little tease showing us she's
not afraid to get her hands dirty and
moby assigns mmm
since his full name is mobius m moebius
and i love the hallways labyrinthian
design like notice the third quarter
is the same set as the first one that
they walked down like the set designers
just doubled it up
maybe as a way to make loki seem lost
and helpless in the tva
now the elevator's descent was shot in
the real life atlanta marriott marquis i
was wondering
tilts down you can see how they actually
recomposited the lower levels with those
big timekeeper statues and the
bookshelves of the tva archives no the
timekeepers are there we're talking
about the variance destruction of
central california oil fields if you
look closely this would be another oil
field that she destroyed after that one
in oklahoma last episode maybe
she genuinely is trying to reverse the
impact of climate change
hmm wait is that was that something that
was brought up
not that i'm at this point but hey you
know it would be an
interesting direction to go down i mean
she's at least hiding amongst natural
disasters and things like that you could
loop that in it would be a more
interesting way of
dealing with that villain trope as of
late understand what do you think
of thanos in himself background of this
library setting you can actually see the
floors behind loki reading
syf lk3 2w1 all of these correspond to
floors in the elevator
but one of them is 372 which could be a
nod to thor 372 which is the first
atomic appearance of the timekeepers
just when i was like come on
that makes sense no it's perfect that is
a
right there true do you go from uh you
just find any random numbers and it says
from a comic book and then oh wait it's
a very specific type
the librarian shuts loki down saying the
creation of the tva the beginning of
time the end of time these are all
classified
just another sign that tva narrative
commission's video about the history of
timekeepers
may or may not be the full story so loki
reads the report on the destruction of
asgard as we saw in thor ragnarok listed
here is a class
7 apocalypse total planetary destruction
9719 deaths which would be the entire
civilization minus the refugees who
escaped on the statesman
and he could also see code name
revengers which is
improvised hell yeah i've got a name
it's a yeah it's called the revenges
revenges because i'm getting revenge
you're getting revenge and you're you
you people what are you you want revenge
and i'm just undecided so loki deduces
from lack of variance energy detected
that their killer must be hiding
which in those societies anyway creating
this example of ruining mobius's salad
and stealing casey's boku fruit juice
kind of like josta another beverage from
the 90s that you cannot get anymore
he also mentions maybe pushing hulk off
the rainbow bridge which bruce branner
very nearly does during that final
battle
loki's mind may also go to that because
hulk having to descend the stairs was
what led to tony bumbling the tesseract
and allowing loki to escape
in a branch timeline loki brings up
another possible apocalyptic events
it could be a tidal wave it could be a
meteor it could be a volcano a supernova
yeah we actually see two of those
huge waves from the hurricane the
volcano mount vesuvius
so we may also see a meteor in a
supernova as upcoming apocalypses on the
show
like that interplanetary calamity teased
in trailer footage
oh it's just going against crazy 79 a.d
you actually see it written in roman
numerals on the wall there as well here
loki tests creating chaos by releasing
these goats be free my own friends be
free
yeah logie calls them his horned friends
referencing his
own horns the horns of all variant
loki's maybe foreshadowing the way he
will let
hornet friends go free mobius talks
about his love of jet skis
in the early 1990s for a brief shining
moment
there was a beautiful union of form
and function which we call the jet ski
as a floridian can confirm jet skis our
peak
form of transportation like you can
imagine a really confined tv
agent must love that solo piloted craft
where you can
wander freely without any speed limits
or traffic lines you have to stay within
if we don't see this management
absurdity of their origin stories
timekeeper space lizards vs
norse mythology and it's real because i
believe it's real actually later marvel
comics linked the asgardian mythology
with the celestials by saying asgardians
are aliens in a certain celestial
mutation cycle
in which the beliefs of those they
protect map onto them
in this case the norse people of midgard
mobius explains that the tva protects
what came before while the timekeepers
untangle the sacred timeline's epilogue
from its infinite branches
that once they're finished no more nexus
events just order and we meet in peace
at the end of time
this would mean that nexus events are
accidents that only occur
because the sacred timeline isn't yet
woven tightly enough
by the time people choose one they
dictate which random strands need to be
clipped
in order to make the rope that stretches
endlessly into the future
perfectly tight and once that process is
complete then they all meet at the end
of all time
wait wait wait what did we just learn
so what they're talking about in that
conversation they're talking about free
will and all that
so they're supposed to be obeying get to
this point where the timeline
is just pure sacred and it's supposed to
go in this very specific way where they
meet at the end of time
it really does seem like that if there
is a time keeper or if it's king the
conqueror yeah if this is a timekeeper
they got to be like the villain of this
right
it would cause it gives you no control
for the main characters or any of
any characters in the marvel universe if
someone else is controlling the fate i
could certainly
i mean that makes for a whole lot of
personal conflicts coming from
characters because i mean part of the
whole first episode was loki grappling
with the idea that yeah
i'm just a prop for other people's
greatness and nothing i do matters and
you know i have this one track fatalism
of that degree
can i think build a sort of tension and
a villainous
angle if you're looking at it the right
way because who wants to be confined to
a life like that so i can certainly see
something where both the timekeepers are
revealed maybe not to be who they say
they are
it's interesting to me because it puts
you at odds with something that isn't
necessarily
good or bad but you can very much
understand why someone would be vexed to
find out that it is their
reality i mean if we're looking forward
to a multiverse of madness it just seems
like yeah the
all this hard work keeping the timeline
tight
is probably going to be undone pretty
soon oh yeah
and we're saying nexus events or
accidents so i mean all that stuff in
one division is an accident
that's what it seems like yeah so we're
watching what
leads to the madness yeah it seems like
and
and maybe yeah like maybe the events of
wand division will be amplified when
whatever
the conclusion of loki is happens where
yeah maybe her
hex uh you know is is under some of the
laws and decrees that the timekeepers
have in place right now but when that
all comes apart who knows you know
what's going to become of her power and
everything else
yeah i don't think so no mobius
remembers that kablooey gum from episode
one
candy you have candy on asgard yeah
grapes nuts
i wonder you're so bitter actually
remember when lucky posed as odon asgard
he snacked on grapes while watching that
play
since that gum was only sold on earth
from 2047 to 2051 they look at various
disasters like the climate disaster of
2048 the tsunami of 2051
the 2050 extinction of the swallow and
the 2049 eruption of krakatoa
which is a volcanic island in indonesia
that erupted in 1883 and apparently will
erupt again
yeah quite a bleak picture for earth in
the coming 30 years
can't wait but they zero in on the rocks
cart disaster
class 10 apocalypse when a category 8
hurricane hit haven hills alabama in
2050.
now the report says entire town
annihilated 10
835 humans dead but planetary body
intact
meaning there are worse calamities
coming where the planet will be
destroyed with a reference to another
case file
when that happens category 8 hurricane
is just depressing
since the scale really only goes up to
category five meaning
future meteorologists must adjust the
scale for increasingly powerful storms
due to the rise of global ocean
temperatures
now rox cart with the two x's is an odd
to roxanne that's the energy
conglomerate of marvel comics that have
shown up in the background of iron man
movies
in the future they apparently build and
enjoy their spider-man
massive costco style superstores because
why not branch out in retail right by
the way another marvel corporation
advanced idea mechanics aim from iron
man 3 actually made a little cameo in
episode
one as the maker of that shovel from the
year twenty twenty two
oh so mobius gives loki back daggers
which hunter b-15 immediately
confiscates
i love that since the camera follows
them into the locker room without
cutting they have to time
woundee's entrance perfectly so that
she'll be right there to snatch them a
second wow
the actors and the director go into good
old-fashioned comedic timing just via
blocking
that's what i mean man this show is
composed
it is a composed series and i love
it and we got six of them
that's right man it's composed by the
time keepers themselves it's that good
it says you really get the sense for
like meticulous craftsmanship like
true quality filmmaking absolutely yeah
and on multiple
levels you know too like you could
really feel so many departments really
kicking ass in this
yeah but the direction especially yeah
and the writing whatever
and the cgi and the acting and the
background oh haven hills 2050
is revealed with this electronic
billboard of the peaceful seaside town
with rocks on smokestacks
polluting the sky which of course leads
to the climate disaster that's now
consuming it
so that this billboard blows down
revealing its true status right behind
before and after beachfront now washed
way in
tons of flooding structures collapsing
buildings exploding
this has got to be my favorite disaster
imagery of any marvel title i can think
of because it's not at all caused by
invading alien threats or robots run
amok it's just humanity over time
it also neatly reflects this series
production design of futuristic elements
being destructive
and toxic and crappy while the retro
design of the tva
seems perpetual ironclad clean i also
love the little design details they put
into the twenty free trick
store like a holographic greeter in the
parking lot this is
a helper robot employee badges that
light up reading welcome can i help you
also in the break room there is a poster
reading a great place to work a great
place to shop
everything you need for happiness that
shopper is buying azaleas because of a
hurricane
sale meaning that these must be common
enough that roxcart schedules sales
events around
them but this guy turns out to be a lady
loki drone and he transfers his
consciousness to b15 and then to that
employee randy and then finally to this
hoss and like c20 b15 wakes up from lady
loki's possession
shivering coming back from some curse
that rattled her to her core
c20 reveals that she told lady loki
where the timekeepers are
meaning that they are probably the true
target of this sacred timeline bombing
but how does she know where the
timekeepers are but mobius doesn't
that's the biggest question i've had
so far i think is is yeah like why
would one of the minutemen know if no
analysts know
and it's like judge level thing to know
the men and men probably have do they
have authority over
mobius because b15 seemed to be calling
the shots a little bit when it came to
them going into the roxon shopping corps
but it might have been just because of
the mission of who has
higher in command ranking yeah i mean
i've i keep getting the sense that
they're almost on some kind of even
playing field in terms of the hierarchy
and just when you're out in the field
you know it's
it's b15s crew and it's the rest of the
minute like they're obviously gonna
listen to her way more than mobius but
it does make me wonder how the internal
hierarchy of the tva
actually worked because yeah just why
would she have
the in for like the most crucial piece
of information in the known universe
theoretically
finally the villain reveals her face
isn't about you so it is confirmed
sophia diamartino is playing a female
loki variant most likely lady loki now
in the comics lady loki is not
really an alternate timeline variant but
loki's disembodied soul
after ragnarok reincarnated into a
female body however that still might be
the case here
since this loki can transfer her soul
into new bodies
she may just be a human female that
loki's soul decided to stay
in but also notice that one of the horns
on her crown is broken
off could be a nod to loki's looking
agent of asgard
or a reflection of how she might not
consider herself a true loki the way she
told loki
i'm not a true little man she may be
someone with a style curse but go by
silly
also she might be telepathic because as
she reveals herself listen closely
you can hear tom hiddleston's voice
echoing in that
what is this about this isn't about you
yeah making her words here a response to
loki's thoughts
so using stolen reset charges and stolen
temp ads
she bombs the sacred timeline creating
branches throughout time and space
rinse players screen actually shows a
lot of the dates and locations
we gotta break these down here's the
chrome monitor room you can see
nowhere that's a severed celestial head
location the guardians of the galaxy and
then barcelona
and then below nithlaheim that's the
asgardian realm
that hella was believed to be exiled in
and then dartford england but then on to
rinslayer screen
you see august 3rd 1522 fong naw vietnam
march 31st 1492 lisbon portugal
that's something related to columbus's
atlantic voyage that year
april 23rd 23rd premiere premiere well
here's the rest of the places
get that red skull back 23rd was
infinity war's release date in 2015.
october 25th 1551 thornton colorado
november 22nd 1999
cookeville tennessee and then february
16th for
asgard so the home of loki and thor
eight years or so
prior to the events of the first thor
film october 3rd 1390
rome italy i'm assuming some kind of
vatican drama there
august 13 1984 sakar teo
so again it's a card from thor ragnarok
tayo is the name of its star system
1984 could have been during the reign of
one of those past
arena champions that we saw on the
outside of the building february 2nd
1808 maricara colombia july 17
1700 pervu finland december 17th
showing that yeah this guy was planting
seeds around the galaxy for over seven
hundred years
oh hell yeah peter's mother october 13
1982
titan thanos grew up on in the ruins of
which he fought the avengers upon an
infinity war 1982 could have been around
when titan came upon
environmental ruin that set thanos on
his mission september 21st 1947 new york
new york i was thinking cap's return
date and end game but i think that was
confirmed to be 1948.
march 1st 1984 tokyo january 3rd 51
a.d holla holla is the cree home world
seen in captain marvel
they reached peak evolution years before
humanity did so this could be right in
the midst of their advanced races
history
august 2nd 1999 kingsport tennessee
september 24th
[Music]
now xandar is the home to the nova corps
seen in guardians of the galaxy november
23rd 2005 beijing
july 18 1903 madrid and then above the
time doors you can also see
portland in 2004 oh my god oh jesus oh
my god
oaky's home realm land of the frost
giants now i plan to dig more
into each of these dates and locations
because i think lady loki might have
targeted each of these specifically to
alter history so i'll be digging into
that multi-versa badness
multiverse staff likely realizing that
variant's real plan is to flush out tva
agents leaving it undefended so that she
can get to the timekeepers
lady loki is headed now loki close
behind either to stop her or to join her
but in either case
not according to the script at the
sacred timeline and i love that we don't
know
we don't know what it is for everything
loki thanks for watching bye
brilliant job again damn thank you for
what you do
good pick up on detail in the telepath
part too
yeah great detail i mean that we don't
know for sure that could have just been
some type of
audio design to enhance the moment of
the scene i mean if it is it's a cool
like uh a hint towards it as well
in your head i'm expecting episode three
to start off
on a literal big bang let's see how this
goes right
see how the whole timeline has been
affected by this
all right guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below subscribe to new rockstars if
you haven't done so already
they are the best and we have had the
pleasure of collabing with them before
meeting them and uh eric voss especially
has been incredibly kind human being to
us hit that like button
niraj krishnan it's your shout out today
i hope you're safe i hope you're doing
well i miss
seeing your face and your music
recommendations
you always have some interesting movies
and stuff that you're watching
but also you know how to kick some good
tunes
i'm just uh you weren't supposed to
break characters trying not to it's
really hard
garage i want to also see what your
variants are i feel like you out of
everybody would have a bunch of
interesting variants i want to see like
a punk rock narage
like a hulked out in a raj sexy bondage
narage i want to see narage
but with like button eyes like in
coraline i want to see a
reg version of niraj john version of
mirage
eric voss version of niraj loki niraj
we're just gonna keep going until this
thing cuts uh how's it about
i gotta edit the video so
niraj thanks for being a patron buddy